[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es wieder ein
klassisches rezept und zwar berliner
brot mich erinnert berliner brot so ein
bisschen an magenbrot sondern man das
bei uns in der region ich weiß nicht ob
es das deutschlandweit gibt jedenfalls
ist das wie so eine art ich weiß nicht
ob ich wie so eine art lebkuchen sagen
kann es ist süß man ist zu weihnachten
und es ist wirklich sehr lecker hat auch
viele kalorien aber das ist egal das hat
alles bei mir auf dem kanal zumindest
alles wissen rezepte und es ist wie so
eine art gewürz kuchen in kleinen form
ja und ich sind wirklich ziemlich lecker
und das hier setzen ganz traditionelles
rezept was ich mit euch teile von
freunden aus berlin
ich zeige euch mal eben die zutaten
lasst euch bitte nicht abschrecken es
sind viele zutaten aber auch ein großes
blech ohne große menge und es hat soma
rezept um die omas die haben halt immer
eine große menge zubereitet für die
ganzen kinder und enkelkinder
dafür verwende ich 350 gramm braunem
zucker 150 gramm zuckerrübensirup für
eine prise salz
ich habe ich noch nutzer und mandeln und
zwar 300 gramm nüsse 100 gramm mandeln
die werden gemahlen 500 gramm mehl 60
gramm kakaopulver eineinhalb teelöffel
backpulver zwei teelöffel zimt und einen
teelöffel nelken beides bereits gemalt
jeweils 100 gramm mandeln und haselnüsse
die bleiben ganz 150 gramm getrocknete
kirchen ihr könnt auch cranberries
nehmen und 250 gramm butter die wird
gleich noch verflüssigt und zwar wird
ganz traditionell viel zucker verwendet
den bekommt man ganz gut auch in holland
zum beispiel den niederlanden
aber ihr könnt doch einfach braunen
zucker nehmen und zuckerrübensirup und
dann hatte eben auch diesen schönen
maligen geschmack den brauchen wir jetzt
hier nämlich und jetzt gebt ihr zuerst
den braunen zucker in eine rührschüssel
ihr könnt auch mit dem handrührgerät
arbeiten dann den zuckerrübensirup der
ist ja auch ganz klassisch und wird auch
ganz oft bei lebkuchen verwendet da mag
man auch diesen geschmack und natürlich
gibt er nicht nur den geschmack sondern
eben auch eine schöne farbe
hier kommen noch die eier mit rein was
für ein farbspiel hier
und die prise salz und jetzt lasse ich
das hier schön verrühren bis der zucker
sich fast aufgelöst hat und ich nutze
die zwischenzeit um schon mal die
mandeln und haselnüsse zu malen aber
nicht die zwei kleinen schälchen die
möchte ich im ganzen rhein geben sondern
nur dieses große schälchen und ich mal
den was selber weil das auch immer
einfach viel viel intensiver ist
[Musik]
jetzt hat sich der zucker aufgelöst und
spiele mit ganz kurzen steht noch aus
aber ich benutze ihn gleich wieder
muttermilch alles einfacher einführen
kann
und jetzt gibt es wirklich keine
reihenfolge sondern es kommen alle
zutaten hier ein achtes weder
schneebesen raus ich bin nicht gleich
der flach höhere denn mit dem
schneebesen wer das jetzt ein bisschen
zu anstrengend oder nehmt den knethaken
dazu die butter ist jetzt auch schon
flüssig
die zierkirschen ihr könnt aber auch
cranberries nehmen oder die bären auch
weglassen wenn ihr gar keine möglich
jetzt noch die ganzen mandeln mit rein
die gemahlenen mandeln sind drin also
wirklich alles einfach rein
ich frage mich jetzt nur gleich wie man
eine maschine schaffen fragt ihr euch
das auch ja wahrscheinlich
und so schafft das aber ich nehme den
knethaken
und jetzt einfach alles verbinden
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig und ich nehme jetzt
einfach einen bug rahmen den habe ich
jetzt hier auf meinen lochblech gesetz
mit einer dauer back folie den ziel
jetzt auf blech größer aus das ersetzt
im prinzip ein herkömmliches backblech
und dadurch dass ich jetzt hier ein
lochblech darunter habe und sich hier
ganz gut sagt alles etwas gleichmäßiger
und schneller durch
wenn man eben eine hitzeverteilung hat
und ihr könnt es jetzt entweder so
backen oder nimmt die back opladen
darunter die nehme ich jetzt hier
drunter
ich mag es auch verlebten ganz gerne zum
einen klebt nicht an eurem backblech an
und zum anderen habt ihr unten einfach
nochmal schönebeck opladen schicht die
das ganze abrunden
einfach schön auslegen so ein bisschen
überlappend schokoladen konfekt handele
wie wäre es mit einem konfekt murat a
vielleicht finde ich noch ein konfekt
was sich murat ländern jetzt nehmt ihr
diesen klebrigen teig diese klebrige
masse und verteilt sich darauf die
richter jetzt schon richtig gut
und die habe ich jetzt ein schälchen mit
wasser wird meine hände etwas befeuchten
und dann den teig einfach platt drücken
[Musik]
so sieht's jetzt aus und bisher war es
ja echt recht einfach also ich finde so
ein bisschen teig zusammen mischen und
dann aufs blech streichen
sehr einfach ein gutes weihnachtsgebäck
und es kommt jetzt so erstmal in den
backofen darf gebacken werden und dann
hole ich es raus und es geht sofort heiß
weiter also mit dem blech gibt es gleich
weiter auf einem kanal es geht heiß
weiter gut meine stimme ist heiser
deswegen hier geht es gleich heiß weiter
ich wollte dich sagen jedenfalls geht es
da drin heiß weiter und starben danach
halt in der küche
[Musik]
hier ist das berliner brot ist es noch
warm und jetzt habe ich hier puderzucker
und wasser die zwei zutaten vermischt
ich jetzt und bestreichen dann das
berliner brot direkt noch ganz heiß mit
dieser klausur damit eben schön einsehen
kann
was ist so sagen was du willst mir
dönerfleisch und paar pommes hier bist
du ein fleischmesser das später
probieren
nachdem dörfler schmeckt ja ja die
werden wir dann wieder zur oma geht also
normalerweise finde ich glaube ich dir
ja so besser mit zitrone ich bin so ein
zitronen puderzucker liebhaber ich habe
jetzt mit wasser gemacht ich probiere es
gleich mal so und ich schneide jetzt
auch gleich direkt schon in kleine
stücke wenn ich ein paar minuten
abkühlen lassen
ja was musst du tun
nein ein blitz reindrücken
ich glaube die oma ist fertig
ich bin mutig nein michelle lag ein
blitz ein drücken
ein blitz das recht gut aber wir machen
jetzt wieder weg
[Applaus]
ich schneide sie jetzt 3 x 4 cm groß
[Musik]
eins muss ich vielleicht noch sagen mir
wurde gesagt dass sich das berliner bot
besser schneiden lässt im warmen zustand
ich hab's mal ausprobiert an dem rand
stück und es ist echt besser im kalten
zustand hat man eine schönere
schnittkante und dann reicht es nicht so
ein
jetzt lasse ich den salat probieren ja
also eigentlich muss man das jetzt
verpacken dennis kopf zerschlagen werden
muss das eigentlich packen und dann erst
nach zwei drei tagen probieren
doch dann zieht es nochmals durch und
wird saftiger und so aber ich hab mir
gedacht komm jetzt schon probieren ja
was soll wenn es so trocken wie merken
sollten ist es was diese zwiebelkuchen
oder ja stimmt rallye bevor das was
süßes genau hin zum parken ja ja so
ähnlich aber ich finde alles jetzt schon
probiert schmeckt nicht wie magenbrot
als berliner rothmann bord sind zwei
relativ verschiedene dinge gut dann noch
auf das schönste stück ja durch keine
aller gängigen wann wir uns ein bisschen
voraus beides und kirschen die kirche
mischt ausgeschmückt jetzt aber ich bin
mein ganzes und ingenieure kennt diese
eine schokolade ganze nuss heißt ihr
nachfolgen mit bloßem auge müssen wenn
man sie uns und reden von unten
ich musste raus und dann soll es zum
schluss gegessen aber ich muss das beste
war was mir schmeckt also ich bin für
immer weg man kann sogleich auf gewann
glaube ich ja also ich verrate es jetzt
auch schön und dann lass uns noch mal
durch zehn mal probieren noch mal so im
zwei drei tagen
aber ich denke auch von tag zu tag
schmeckt ist immer besser für den
kommissar max greger
tennis gibt das heißt berliner brot und
ist die linzer torte wird jetzt von tag
zu tag besser schmeckt
das freut mich die ganze chose gegen den
gewürzen gibt ja also uns schmeckt sehr
gut ich probiere gerne aus und ihr seht
ihr ein blech gebacken und dann entsteht
so eine riesenportion ihr könnt es jetzt
auch richtig schön verpacken in so
kleinen tütchen und dann verschenken so
eine schöne weihnacht cds geschenkidee
für die nachbarn zum beispiel können
doch was schönes packen und dann einfach
verteilen oder für die schule für das
lichterfest selbstgemachte ihr
selbstgemachtes berliner brot und dann
einfach in der schule so verkaufen
wer schon kohle ja also viel spaß beim
nachhaken und bis zum nächsten mal
und wenn ihr doch eine haltung ist
allagui habt oder allergie das zweck und
ersetzt zum beispiel dann eben durch
wandeln und ansonsten aber so ganz
weglassen so hassen dass ein wandel will
ich schon ich also wenn man eine harte
nuss allagui hat jahren im team anderen
stattdessen aber so ganz ohne mandeln
und ganz ohne hasen ist er ist schon was
mit walnüssen
wann ist er ja aber ich meine wenn man
eine allergie hat gestimmt
du machst du ganz ohne glaube ich ich
glaube da gibt es echt keine guten
ersatz dann würde ich lieber lebkuchen
machen
[Musik]